[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ross tucker host of the ross tucker
football podcast works for cbs westwood
one as a color analyst joining us uh
great to see you again ross zacharch
just got traded from the eagles to the
cardinals can zachary's play
this sunday when the cardinals play the
browns
no he's not he can't dan uh but that
would be funny if he could
uh no the nflpa you're only allowed to
play one game
per week so he'll be on the sideline
watching his new team play
um i will say this though dan back in
2002
i got two bye weeks which was nice
i was in washington had an early buy
got cut by spurrier went to dallas got
another buy i mean dan i was almost bad
enough that if i had kept getting cut by
teams i might have been able to get five
or six buys in that week that year
do you have a favorite steve spurrier
story
oh my gosh
uh so
probably my favorite is that
if there was even a threat of rain i got
two if there was even a threat of rain
he would cancel practice because
washington did not have an indoor
facility so this is back when marvin
lewis was the first million dollar
coordinator that washington brought in
so it would drizzle
and spurrier would cancel practice and
marvin lewis would be like no no coach
we gotta go we gotta practice the other
one is dan
i i swear to you
as god is my witness
he had no sight adjustments or hot reads
in his offense
explaining what yes what's that explain
that
yeah so a hot reader a sight adjustment
is when the defense blitzes more guys
than you have to protect and so the
quarterback has to throw the ball he has
to throw and the receiver has to see it
because the receiver has to know oh man
this guy is coming he's going to throw
the ball at me right away
spur didn't have those spurrier expected
the quarterback to audible
so
in patrick ramsey's first start
he was a first round pick from tulane
we're playing the saints at home
the saints dan look like they're
bringing a blitz from the right
and ramsey's going through his cadence
and spurrier says patrick patrick
patrick
and and ramsay looks over and he says
ringo slide ringo slide because it
looked like the saints were coming from
the right and ramsey is a rookie from
two lanes he looks i was like okay okay
coach okay we're gonna go slide ringo
slide
as soon as he does that the saints
rotate the safe
and they look like they're coming from
the left and spurner goes patrick
patrick patrick ramsay looks over
blue slide blue slide ramsay goes okay
okay
delay a game delay game
dan i was sitting there thinking this is
the nfl dude this is the nfl and the
head coach is screaming audibles to the
rookie quarterback to make them and we
just ran out of time i i knew it was
going to be we would be in trouble after
that
uh you were on the call with last
night's game with the eagles and the
buccaneers let me start with uh jalen
hurts jalen hurts the answer
long term
don't know yet um i do know
that he is competing every week
with all of the other available options
as it stands right now
because the eagles have the dolphins
first round pick
because of that horrible trade by the
dolphins this off season to move up from
12 to 6 and give up next year's first
round pick
and very likely to get the colts first
round pick as long as wentz plays 75
percent
right now the eagles have three picks in
the top eight
i believe in certainly top ten yeah and
a lot of people think veterans like
russell wilson desean watson
maybe even aaron rodgers are all going
to be available which is to say
jalen hurts is essentially competing
against all of the other options that
will be available to the eagles after
this season because of their their draft
capital
explain brady doing it again now granted
it's against the eagles he did have two
touchdowns did throw an interception was
there anything in of interest with you
with brady last night
um i mean he didn't throw a single bad
pass in the first half there was two
incompletions one can break dropped the
other one antonio brown got pushed out
you know
i was just about to tweet last night dan
at halftime at ross tucker nfl the guy
is a robot but then he actually had a
couple bad throws in the second half i
don't know what happened to him but he
had a couple throws you know you know
why some people
never give him
the credit dan it's because
he doesn't do the spectacular
like rogers
or
mahomes or josh allen
and what he does brady's greatness
is
consistently doing the routine
over and over and over and over again
and that's not on the highlights it
never makes brady never makes people go
wow when they're watching him play the
wow is that he's just good every single
time
he's the nfl's version of tim duncan
yes
yes
that's a great that's a great comparison
it's like
we
and you're you're to blame for this by
the way dan we live in a we live in a
highlight society we live in a society
that all anybody cares about is what's
on sportscenter or now what's on the
internet you started that with the
awesome show at the mothership the four
letter network but with every passing
year
we care less about consistent
performance and more about
highlights and the special and
the stuff we that wows us and nothing
that brady does wows us other than the
success i'm also wondering what what
happened here what did i miss where it's
open season on patrick mahomes and now
all of a sudden you know people are
going i'd take josh allen over patrick
mahomes i'd take justin herbert over
patrick mahomes what what happened here
um our attention spans are about 10
minutes
and he had a couple games where he had
turnovers i mean he's still unbelievable
and
the chief's defense is the worst in the
nfl i heard you
yesterday or one of these days i was
listening and i i heard you pump the
brakes on having anybody better than
mahomes and i'm with you like josh
allen's been great this year herbert's
been great this year
i'm still taking the homes over anybody
for the next 10 years that guy is
ridiculous
and a couple of turnovers and a terrible
defense that doesn't change that
yeah they're suddenly vulnerable but and
i love herbert and josh allen i need to
see a little bit more from them
because we have seen more from patrick
mahomes i just think we we're doing a
disservice to patrick mahomes they've
never had a great defense
they've had a capable defense maybe an
opportunistic defense now they have a
horrible defense and i couldn't help but
look back to you know
edwards hillary that they took him at
the end of the first round instead of
taking a defensive player um you know we
we get into those grades hey this guy's
the highest graded guy still on our
boards
i i gotta go for need i gotta go for
what what's smart here and you know the
the the cowboys got you know trayvon
diggs in the second round like you know
granted they got michael parsons in the
first round but the difference between
the cowboys and the chiefs is
that cowboys have a defense they have a
couple of players who can play defense
right now
and i think he'll never say this
publicly i think it affects how mahomes
plays sure i think mahomes is more
aggressive because he knows the defense
stinks you know the other thing is dan
we all love the new thing right so we
all
love herbert now herbert's kind of the
new thing
so we always are looking for next and
mahomes is also a product
of the expectations you know he's just
set the bar so high
that if he doesn't always meet it every
week it's like
oh he's not playing as well whereas alan
and herbert are still in the position to
be able to exceed our expectations
always great to talk to you ross will be
uh on the call yale and uconn tomorrow
that's uh on cbs sports network the
nutmeg state battle wow you throw out
the records when those two get together
listen
the nutmeg state this this is for
bragging rights in the nutmeg state for
decades tomorrow at noon cbs sports
network thank you ross that's ross
tucker host of the ross tucker football
podcast has anybody had nutmeg by the
way
we we work in the nutmeg state i don't
know if i've had nutmeg